ce matin-là jean-françois su à ce pilote
de bateau part à la rencontre d'un
paquebot unique au monde
al'approche on appréhende à peine la
taille de sa démesure
qu'est ce que vous ressentez quand vous
voyez un bateau comme ça arriver à
marseille
je suis à menton en marin effectivement
je suis pas cinéaste et ses gammes le
bureau il est il un design assez
extraordinaire l'arrière est ouvert et
là c'est vraiment le bateau un peu de
tous les superlatifs
l'alu rock de 6 est le plus grand navire
de croisière de la planète 360 mètres de
l'ong 6000 passagers 25 restaurants 2
simulateur de surf
un gigantisme américain d'ordinaire
réservé aux caraïbes qui fait désormais
escale à marseille depuis le mois de mai
a eu 5 pour de choisir méditerranée il
ya eu 5 sur les caraïbes donc il n'a
fréquenté que dix ports depuis sa
naissance dont celui de marseille la
grande fierté en tant que marché c'est
de voir que des gens pourront quitter
marseille avec une image renouvelée et
donc l'attractivité nouvelle et un
rayonnement à travers le monde
toutes les semaines le géant des mers
s'arrête dans le port de la capitale
provençale
une fois les 100 mille tonnes du
paquebot solidement amarré à la terre
ferme
les milliers de touristes peuvent enfin
débarquer pour visiter les rues de
marseille
une première photo souvenir et ses
visiteurs rejoignent les bus à
destination du centre ville
des flots de touristes du monde entier à
contre-courant de la mauvaise réputation
de marseille qui voudraient la ville
sale et dangereuse selon kevin l'un des
managers de la croisière aucun de ces
étrangers n'en a jamais entendu parler
nos petits préjugés franco-français sur
marseille
les objets totalement abandonné dia
comme celui-ci on est à l'échelle du
monde
tous les matins on arrivé à marseille
avec larbi sortait sur les peaux vous
allez voir là la côte qui est vraiment
superbe c'est une des plus belles
arrivées depuis la croisière
le point commun des voyageurs un pouvoir
d'achat important qui leur a permis de
se payer une croisière à 2000 euros par
personne désormais des visiteurs du bout
du monde viennent découvrir marseille
alors qu'avant la ville se contenter
d'un tourisme européen
et comme romelu egypte egypte c'est
super design ou bas où est ce que c'est
c'est une île au large du venezuela
new york première fois à marseille oui
ils vous pensez quoi de la ville serait
sa part c'est très beau
j'aime les femmes d'ici mai
après la corniche le coût de la visite
s'est bien sûr notre dame de la garde et
la bonne mère sainte patronne des
marseillais les touristes comme ces
brésiliens sont époustouflés relatant
des félicitations
cette ville est magnifique je suis très
surpris je ne pensais pas que c'était
beau à ce point là le nombre de
touristes à marseille a doublé en trois
ans elle la villa accueille aujourd'hui
5 millions de visiteurs chaque année
il faut dire que l'état la région et la
mairie n'ont pas lésiné sur les moyens
[Musique]
toute une partie de la cité s'embellit
et progresse depuis 2013 le centre a été
entièrement rénové et sécurisé pour
accueillir les nouveaux touristes les
plus beaux ambassadeurs du renouveau de
marseille ce sont les nageurs du cercle
depuis trois ans est devenue la
meilleure école de natation monde qui
accueille des athlètes hors norme
champion du monde champion du monde
voilà c'est marseille qui viennent
l'échelle mondiale en exclusivité nous
avons pu passer quelques jours dans les
coulisses de cette écurie de champions
en compagnie des beaux gosses du sport
international
florent manaudou camille lacourt et
frédérick bousquet
saison a démarré
le renouveau de la ville c'est aussi une
grue à chaque coin de rue marseille est
le plus grand chantier de france les 7
rénovation se heurtent de plein fouet à
l'une des difficultés locales
les projets sont gangrénés par le racket
le nouveau marseille est en réalité à
deux vitesses pendant que le vieux port
et le front mais rayonne d'autres
arrondissements décroche en plein centre
il y à même le quartier le plus pauvre
de france le 3e arrondissement
[Musique]
le trafic de drogue est florissant les
policiers tentent chaque jour de
reconquérir les immeubles tombée aux
mains des couleurs vous savez que vous
pourrez tomber pour trafic de
stupéfiants la la deuxième métropole de
france est à la croisée des chemins
après des décennies d'abandon marseille
va mieux
écartelé entre sa rénovation et ses
vieux démons
marseille sera t-elle un jour une ville
comme les autres
[Musique]
a marseille une immense star française
peut parfois se cacher derrière une
devanture anonyme
[Musique]
camille lacourt chéri de ces dames et
des bassins au palmarès aussi séduisant
que son sourire
[Musique]
double champion du monde de natation
option 50 m dos ses yeux bleu piscine
pour le bonheur des marques et de ses
assistantes une centaine de shooting au
compteur mais il fait encore de petites
erreurs donc ça c'est la stresser il est
tendu entre gevrey plaisir c'est quand
elle fait le repassage
romain c'est le meilleur moment de
châtillon attention c'est chaud quand
c'est bon pour passer il y encore peu ce
shooting n'aurait jamais eu lieu à
marseille
mais à paris dans un studio photo
spécialisés désormais la ville change
entraînant dans son sillage toute une
nouvelle économie
souriant léger en fait juste un peu
l'élève qu'il ait l'air serein content
si camille lacourt est devenu une icône
bien au delà des frontières de la
natation c'est aussi grâce au travail de
son agent jean françois salessy camilla
dépassé les frontières de son sport
aujourd'hui de nombreuses marques se
battent pour avoir camille lacourt il
représente le glamour même au niveau
international
une forme de french touch les grandes
marques font des nageurs leur
ambassadeur comme ce fabricant de
téléphones portables qui a tenu à offrir
à camille le dernier modèle de sa
collection
si on sait pas où on va on se rappelle
d'où on vient et moi je connais camille
avec le new york à 52 60
la fiat punto et c'était y'a pas si
longtemps c'est difficile de faire
paraître stats avec tout ça mais je les
ai prises je me poserai la question mon
full en mer des gens non c'est pas fan
non juste il suffit de profiter sans
sans oublier d'où on vient avec les gens
qui m'entourent je risque pas de changer
humble et souriant camille sait ce qu'il
doit à marseille sa ville d'adoption
j'adore ce levier j'adore le caractère
cas là même si quelquefois ça déborde
mais voilà je préfère une ville à
caractère qu une ville trop lisse les
nageurs marseillais sont les beaux
gosses du sport mondial
[Musique]
florent manaudou camille lacourt fabien
gilot frédérick bousquet ont tous en
commun d'être bardé de titres et de
tatouage mais aussi d'appartenir au même
club le prestigieux cercle des nageurs
de marseille
[Applaudissements]
sur la corniche au sud de la ville le
club bénéficie d'un cadre à couper le
souffle
pour la première fois une caméra a pu
filmer les coulisses de cette usine à
champions
fondée en 1921 le cercle des nageurs
étaient au bord de la faillite il y a
dix ans avant de devenir en quelques
années la meilleure école de natation au
monde
l'un des artisans de cette réussite
internationale
c'est paul leccia le patron du cercle
champion du monde champion du monde et
champion olympique en peluche plusieurs
fois champion du monde 2 et plusieurs
fois médaillé olympique
une suprématie qui fait rayonner
marseille à une échelle sans précédent
et ces jeunes garçons ils représentent
l'avenir et représente marseille
représente la france voilà c'est
marseille qui viennent l'échelle
mondiale au cercle des nageurs les
membres anonymes côtoient les étoiles de
la natation
voyez là bas là bas vous avez des gosses
qui sait shop et il c'est chaud entre la
et actuel et si vous avez les champions
finale et donc ils se côtoient
régulièrement
c'est ce qui me plaît ça quelque part ça
leur fait du bien pour avancer avant de
sauter dans la piscine
il y a toujours la séance de torture
pour les nageurs la musculation un enjeu
crucial
possible
mais être champion olympique de natation
ne s'improvise pas c'est l'un des sports
les plus durs physiquement
[Musique]
je sais
s'il ya un secret à toutes les victoires
de marseille c'est d'avoir transformé
une discipline individuelle et solitaire
on sports collectifs ailleurs chaque
nageur à son propre entraîneur ici c'est
romain barnier qui coachent tous les
champions
donc si vous essayez de comprendre la
logique qu'à 300 de préparation quatre
fois 50 d'exploitation chaque semaine
ils enchaînent des dizaines de
kilomètres de carreaux du nom de ce
qu'il voit au fond de la piscine saison
a démarré la mise à l'eau et joueuses
mais à l'entraînement
les nageurs ce défi pour mieux se
stimuler pas que c'est bien tu as deux
moments de cinq minutes dans
l'entraînement fait les biens comme ça
c'est parfait les enjeux de son de
garder notre âme collective c'est de
réussir des sélections olympiques on va
pouvoir emmener un maximum d'athlètes
marseillais contrairement à ses nageurs
romain barnier est né à marseille et il
est fier de pouvoir participer à redorer
le blason de sa ville
ils viennent tous pleins d'endroits et
aujourd'hui se sentent marseillais ça le
plus beau et et rendent marseille fier
donc oui oui il n'y a pas mieux comme il
n'y a pas mieux comme un rêve pour un
minot marseillais que de faire gagner
marseille l'entraînement fini l'ambiance
de franche camaraderie reprend le dessus
dans l'équipe a comme lors de cette
petite incartade entre florent manaudou
et camille lacourt pour un simple tapis
de gymnastique
la cour il a jamais ces affaires il a
jamais cette affaire la preuve lui
obligé de me piquer mon tapis
et moi je n'aime pas mais tu irais je
peux même pas être professionnel moi qui
me tire pourtant à chaque fin de séance
et rigoles là il est joli et jaune
cécité cheval à 10,61 fragasso tapis de
sol et je te situes n'est pas d'un
centième le sort étant appelées aussi
voilà ça se joue à pas grand-chose lui
valent les nageurs sa rage jeta
marseille et leur entraîneur doit gérer
des centaines de sollicitations
quotidiennes
est ce que vous pouvez faire une photo
là ici dans trois quatre minutes avec
les gens qui sont là alors on à camille
lacourt est la doublure de camille
lacourt et bien c'est bon à la fin de la
journée après des heures d'efforts
physiques intensifs
les athlètes peuvent enfin profiter des
plaisirs marseillais les nageurs du
cercle habitent tous dans l'un des plus
beaux quartiers de la ville autour du
vallon des auffes dans le 7e
arrondissement de marseille
à la sortie de l'entraînement florent
manaudou le nageur français le plus
titré de l'histoire prend en cours de
guitare avec son ami david walters
safran faut faire pour savoir à un
moment de détente précieux pour
quelqu'un qui s'entraînent 40 heures par
semaine
[Musique]
tout cela est bon d'être au coeur [__]
c'est d'être ko manager franchement je
pense que la vie de rockeur est le mieux
pour allumer les drogués parce que c'est
plus de qui je pense est moins de
contraintes
florent manaudou habitat marseille
seulement depuis quatre ans mais il
défend lui aussi l'image d'une ville
très malmené mais annuelle mais en fait
c'est pas comment elle écrit à la télé
c'est oui mais il ya toujours une part
de vérité mais il ya aussi quelque chose
de caché et la face cachée mais
malheureusement c'est la bonne phase de
marseille donc nous on est déçus
marseillais que ce soit vu comme ça mais
après nous on profite et on se dit que
ça c'est un truc pour nous donc on est
content
l'athlète préféré des français est tombé
amoureux de marseille mais aussi du
sport local plusieurs fois par semaine
le nageur rejoint ses amis dans un bar
le troquer est tout aussi modeste que
florent manaudou est connu bayonne
marseille et son vocabulaire dans toute
sa splendeur
vas-y minot voilà non je pointe là faut
serrer le jeu attend plus qu'une partie
de pétanque
il y a un enjeu ce soir l'invincibilité
de florent manaudou imbattable à tous
les sports
j'ai jamais battue elle même on flipper
il s'est même pas jouer au flipper mais
une commande ici elles causent à essars
est peut-être un moment historique
donc je reste concentré il n'aime pas
perdre a cessé sa particularité
ce sont au sort parce qu'il aime pas
nager mais les vrais perdants
donc j'imagine on verra ce soir
[Applaudissements]
et une fois de plus florent manaudou
sort le coup gagnant
aujourd'hui la pression gagner les
batailles je crois ils sont partants sa
mémoire ah oui
ils sont essentiels on a une chance
folle ici à marseille c'est au pouvoir
être sérieux la journée
professionnellement
sportivement et c est à voir ces moments
de détente qui nous permet de repartir
le lendemain encore plus fort les stars
des bassins ont vite découvert ce que
les marseillais savaient déjà
marseille est une ville qui se nourrit
de plaisirs simples
c'est quand même une vie merveilleuse de
générosité de chaleur et de confort de
vie après des années de marseille
bashing les nageurs du cercle font
rayonner l'image de la cité une ville
qui depuis deux ans a fait peau neuve
[Musique]
de nouvelles infrastructures ont
transformé le coeur de marseille comme
le musée du mucem où le vieux port
rénové est rendue aux piétons une
transformation qui aurait été impossible
sans la sécurisation du centre ville
en première ligne les caméras de
vidéosurveillance plus de 1800 dans
toute la ville
elle symbolise son renouveau sécuritaire
il y a encore deux ans elle captait
quotidiennement des images de vol avec
violence
comme cet arrachage à l'entrée du métro
où cette agression pour dérober un
téléphone mais aujourd'hui les policiers
de la brigade vtt s'ennuierait presque
les 80 agents à vélo recrutés en renfort
ont asséché la délinquance du centre
ville avec cinq mille interpellations
par an il n'y a presque plus de vols
mais heureusement qu'elle a ici parce
qu'avant c'était la guerre
non le centre-ville aussi avant c'était
la guerre mais maintenant qu'elle est
caméra c'est calme les gens ils ont peur
de faire des trucs grâce à cette police
de proximité
habitants et commerçants ont retrouvé la
paix 10 beauce ans est une figure de
marseille
il tient cette charcuterie depuis 35 ans
et préside le comité du quartier
et voilà de son comptoir il a vu
marseille changé de visage
savez vous où ça se passe bien et vous
savez ya quelques années sans arrêt d
investir au voleur au voleur au voleur
aujourd'hui c'est rare et on parle
beaucoup du renouveau de marseille est
ce que vous vous voyez énormément là
c'est quoi une rue main je vu que depuis
2013 et nos populations des touristes
qui sont surpris de la qualité de
marseille
cette habitante du quartier elle un avis
plus mitigé sur la rénovation de la
ville
mais voilà la rénovation la ville de
marseille aujourd'hui c'est fait pour
quelques nantis et du tourisme a baissé
les cds intérêts qui sont absolument pas
ceux du marseillais landa c'est pas
c'est pas vous c'est pas nous je vois
que le vieux port elle a été refusée
l'accalmie a été refait il ya les
tunnels pour circuler c'est pas fait
pour les touristes les touristes
semblent en sécurité dans le centre mais
dès qu'ils sortent des sentiers balisés
il s'expose aux vieux démons de la cité
si marseille se développent une partie
de la ville semble abandonnée par les
pouvoirs publics comme le 3e
arrondissement qui est le quartier le
plus pauvre de france
sébastien est brigadier chef à la
brigade de sécurité du territoire du 3e
arrondissement
la baie est étroit
son équipage vient de recevoir un appel
radio pour vol à l'arraché sur des
vacanciers prévenus tardivement les
policiers renonce à poursuivre les
suspects pour s'occuper des deux
victimes traumatisées
personne n'est blessé
ça va les gars mais moi je suis vivant
je suis content je dirais aux nord
retrait pour être tranquille dit je vais
aller voir ma petite fille ce couple de
touristes voulaient visiter marseille
mal orienté ils se sont égarés dans le
3e arrondissement
à peine dix minutes plus tard le vieil
homme s'est fait arracher sa chaîne en
or
j'ai demandé à personne pour aller les
directions du levier fort soit il va
indiquer la noix qu'on en arrive là
selon sébastien pour un touriste agressé
ce sont des dizaines d'autres perdu pour
la ville un empêtré dans sa mauvaise
image ça nuise à l'image de marseille a
même si les vols arrache son sont en
baisse permanente et constante
malheureusement il y en a toujours qui
se produisent et il suffit d'un vol
harrach pour nuire à l'image de
marseille
ça va un peu mieux la whey allez venez
on va se poser au commissariat ya
quelqu'un qui va vous recevoir pour le
dépôt de pain d'accord il faut
relativiser votre mari va bien vous
allez bien bon voilà après voilà le cas
de ce couple est devenu rare à marseille
les agressions ont baissé de 20% l'année
dernière non là je crois que j'ai réussi
à virer pur fini par partir chez les
directions to vite fait si les vols à
l'arraché diminue le trafic de
stupéfiants et lui florissant dans le 3e
arrondissement de marseille
je la sacoche l'essentiel du trafic est
alimentée par la seule et immense cité
du quartier
félix pyat un supermarché de la drogue
qui génère 5000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires par jour
sébastien et ses collègues ont déclaré
la guerre à ses dealers le commissariat
a une implantation presque unique en
france
juste en bas de la cité félix-pyat
jamais policiers dealers ne se sont
côtoyés d'aussi près une lutte de
territoire où les succès sont content ou
kg de cannabis
[Musique]
on sent maintenant ça va tout soit bien
c'est pas trop et en encourageant pour
protéger les habitants de la cité et
enrayer le trafic
le combat est quotidien les dealers
utilisent chaque centimètre carré de
l'immeuble pour leur business
là par exemple ils se sont approprié les
cadres ils ont soudé des points ici et
ici et ils ont eu leur propre verrous en
fait pour accéder au cas où les
trafiquants se sont accaparés chaque
placard recoins où gaine technique de
l'immeuble pour y cacher de la drogue et
même des armes
sabathia un fusil d'une sacoche
ils veulent pas garder ça domicile donc
c'est mieux pour eux de le mettre les
parties communes ce n'est pas une arme
factice
non c'est compact issa cette carabine 22
long rifle est une des armes favorites
des délinquants mortel même à plus de
100 m les cités de marseille sont armés
c'est pas une légende dans cette année
jean bien sûr nous on mène une guérilla
urbaine contre eux entre le trafic mais
entre dealers c'est la même chose c'est
vraiment des guerres de terrain pour
reprend possession d'un point de vente
puisque il ya tellement d'argent en jeu
si la kalachnikov et larmes la plus
connue à marseille c'est la carabine qui
fait le plus de victimes
elle est utilisée dans la majorité des
règlements de comptes sont bons
1 2 3 ce soir sébastien et ses deux
collègues ont prévu une opération pour
arrêter un des dealers les plus actifs
de la cité le mode opératoire des
policiers est audacieux prenez un banal
pantalon de techniciens et mettez le sur
yoann enquêteurs aguerris de la bst
salissez le ensuite pour qu'il n'ait pas
l'air trop neuf proches ont craché
yoann va partir seul à touchette comme
disent les policiers dans le jargon
il va faire semblant d'acheter de la
drogue pour interpeller le dealer sans
lui laisser le temps de s'échapper une
stratégie dangereuse et plus pas
entièrement mais bon voilà
sébastien insiste pour qu'il prenne sa
matraque dans sa sacoche
il ya aussi une petite caméra on cherche
à se fondre dans la masse et à pénétrer
dans le hall dans le hall du bâtiment où
ça deale voilà donc le but c'est d'être
le plus discret possible et de que les
choufs ne détecte pas la présence heures
du collègue policier afin qu'ils
puissent pénétrer tranquillement dans le
hall et atteindre la position du char
bonheur qui se trouvera certainement
dans les étages supérieurs
l'opération est risquée yoann va
affronter félix pyat son gilet pare
balles pour le protéger en face les
trafiquants sont armés et déterminés à
protéger leur business
son seul lien avec l'extérieur
l'oreillette de son téléphone pour
communiquer avec sébastien c'est lui qui
déclenchera l'arrivée des renforts
attends tu dis que tu veux qu'on
commence à partir yoann s'approche de
l'entrée du hall 1 c'est face à une
silhouette dans la nuit que toute
l'opération va se jouer comme si le
quartier appartenait aux dealers l'homme
fouilles chaque client
elle maquille ludoland là bas qu il doit
s'assurer que yoann n'est pas un
policier
yoann a déjoué la surveillance du
guetteur la porte passée il est
désormais en danger permanent vas-y
vas-y bon bon bon bon bon bon bon bon
non c'est bon il a il est rentré les
rentrées les rampes et sébastien doit
rejoindre johan au plus vite
qui à ce moment là est seul dans félix
pyat derrière la porte le dealer est là
en plein trafic
le policier va tenter de l'interpeller
sans attendre le renfort de ses
collègues
vas-y françoise france pons fausse sacré
sac rivasi donc le bloc le bloc
[Musique]
ouais
tous la tactique a fonctionné
le dealer est arrêté avec le cannabis
sébastien veut maintenant savoir si la
locataire de l'appartement de repli est
une complice c'est à dire si elle a été
payée pour accueillir le trafiquant en
cas de descente de police écoutez moi
vous savez quand même pas tomber pour
trafic de stupéfiants est ce que vous
connaissez répondre à mes questions est
ce que vous connaissez ces personnes la
personne qui a été interpellée
est ce que c'est normal qu'il soit venu
chez web du produit stupéfiant
bon d'accord vous passez par mois et où
la verrière est appelée à charbonnat on
a du produit de l'argent il ya des mecs
qui se rapproche du du point il nous
faudrait un ou deux véhicules en soutien
au pouvoir c'est sucré avec un chacun
d'y jouer et produire
tiens mais à félix pyat sortir et
souvent aussi difficile que rentrée
moi je n'ai en protection et au lanceur
à l'écart hockey d'antan
c'est au dessus personne c'est bon
attention grenade horaire attention ça
caille la sakay race cinq années à sa
droite attention les gars
[Musique]
les habitants sont en pleine
intervention absolument pas là les
ennuis plus qu'autre chose on vous
interpeller un char bonheur et à au
moins 50% de la cité qui est contre nous
au moins grâce à des tactiques sans
cesse renouvelée la bst a réussi son
opération façon on y arrive
régulièrement entre et on peut pas
gagner à tous les coups mais on arrive
quand même hein il faut il faut faire
preuve de ténacité dont la voiture
le dealer rondot serait presque le
costume de la victime
bush deux enfants et surtout il en veut
aux guetteurs du points de deal de ne
pas avoir détecté yohan demont le char
bonheur a de quoi être énervé il risque
entre deux et trois ans de prison ferme
en fonction de ses antécédents il a
fallu la feuille du jour vous inscrire
toutes les transactions qui sont
effectués qui a 20 euros qui a été donné
pour pour le manger
donc c'est à dire qu'ils ont payé les
guetteurs le charbo en kebab etc etc
vous avez le tarif nuit 40 pour la nuit
des années 50 pour l'appartement
certainement un appartement de repli
la femme chez qui le dealer s'étaient
réfugiés seraient bien complices elle
toucherait 50 euros par jour pour servir
d'appartements de repli
[Musique]
en plus du trafic de drogue la plus
vieille ville de france a aussi un gros
problème d'insalubrité
avec près de trente mille habitations
dégradé 40% de ces logements sont
concentrés dans la même zone encore le
3e arrondissement notamment une rue qui
n'a de luxueux que le nom la rue de
versailles
et au numéro 7 un voyage dans ce que
marsa et connaît encore de pires un
immeuble au bord de l'effondrement
que l'on croirait à l'abandon une
couvrant transformer en déchetterie
vous en avez trois là au milieu des
ordures des seringues usagées
houria une habitante ne décolère pas il
s'assoit il fut là le truc là il se met
life une île ce pays qui jette et le
petit vient et les petits enfants y
croire ce jeu là s'en sort lui n'a
jamais décollé du rez de chaussée
à l'étagé les fenêtres sont cassés et
les branchements électriques risque de
court circuit
houria tient à nous montrer l'intérieur
dans des appartements de l'immeuble
huit enfants en bas âge et vivant le
balcon menace de s'écrouler à tout
moment depuis un an
certains locataires se battent pour
obtenir une rénovation de leur immeuble
séverine decaux et leur avocate dans sa
mallette un document très compromettants
pour les propriétaires des appartements
les copropriétaires de l'immeuble sis 7
rue de versailles 3e arrondissement de
marseille doivent sous un délai de six
mois en avril 2014
un arrêté de péril at home sur
l'immeuble les propriétaires ont six
mois pour faire des travaux sous peine
d'amendé les locataires sont eux sensé
être relogés par la mairie de marseille
un an plus tard rien n'a été fait et
tous les appartements sont encore pleins
l'immeuble est dans l'illégalité la plus
totale
on pourra pas venir dire aux habitants
ici que personne est au courant on a un
arrêté du 25 avril 2014
qui dit qu'ici les conditions sont
absolument déplorable et dangereuse pour
tous les habitants le bâtiment garde les
séquelles d'un immense incendie qui a
ravagé la cage d'escalier l'année
dernière les pompiers avaient dû évacuer
en urgence tous les habitants depuis
aucune rénovation n'a été engagée
l'immeuble est toujours aussi dangereux
s'il ya des morts effectivement ce sera
l'amérique qui sera responsable et
propriétaires on pourra se retrouve
effectivement devant une juridiction
pénale pour que ces personnes
irresponsables soit jugé pour homicide
involontaire absolument aujourd'hui
séverine de cause se rend chez une
famille qui vit dans l'un des
appartements les plus dégradées de la
rue c'est l'humidité les murs du salon
sont constellés de champignons noirs
toxiques pour la santé des habitants
c'est scandaleux c'est choquant d'autant
que le propriétaire n'est pas venu on
n'a pas fait les travaux rien n'a été
fait et que vous a dit l'inspecteur
d'insalubrité quand il est venu la
dernière fois qu'est ce qui va se passer
[Musique]
hasard de tournage l'inspecteur
d'insalubrité de la mairie est de
passage dans l'immeuble ce jour là ça
fait quand même quelques temps ça fait
trois ans que vous venez de nous envoyer
des papiers des procès verbaux et des
amendes comme seule réponse la mairie de
marseille serait elle dépassée par
l'insalubrité de la ville que vous étiez
une situation pareille il ya 2 2 ou 3
ans courrier et regardez l'état de
l'état l'appartement j'ai pas un faux
pas de marseille c'est des problèmes qui
ne l'est pas assez insalubres pour être
traité l'explication de l'inspecteur
d'hygiène révolte séverine de copeaux
lui demander de venir vivre ici
peut-être pendant quelques mois
chocolate dira sa part il faut venir
voir les champs c'est une catastrophe
en quoi les enfants dorment à sepang
salut pour l'inspecteur d'insalubrité
quatre enfants vivent dans cette toute
petite chambre se lavent dans cette
salle de bains impraticable et souffre
de graves problèmes de santé
l'armoire à pharmacie des bords de
médicaments pour soigner les troubles
respiratoires difficile parce qu'à
chaque fois les enfants par classe aura
100 voire 150 rue de versailles le
renouveau de marseille se fait toujours
attendre
elle serait bien qu'ils aient un peu
d'argent qu'ils soient dépensés aussi
pour le renouveau du 3e arrondissement
six mois après notre tournage la
situation dans la rue de versailles est
toujours aussi catastrophique depuis
cinq ans l'état pourtant débloqué plus
de 3 milliards d'euros pour rénover
marseille
mais l'essentiel de cet argent a été
investi dans le centre-ville et les
quartiers nord à seulement quelques
centaines de mètres du 3e arrondissement
marseille n'a jamais été autant en
travaux des dizaines de grues constat le
paysage mais une grande partie des
chantiers sont confrontés à un problème
récurrent en mars 2015
la une de la provence va bouleverser le
milieu du btp est rappelé que le premier
frein au renouveau de la ville tient
aussi l'être raquette
[Musique]
les vols sur les chantiers représentent
50 millions d'euros par an dans le
département
intimidation menaces de mort vol
violence la délinquance sur les
chantiers marseillais a augmenté de 35 %
en seulement un an
la rénovation des cités et la l2 sont
perçus comme une déclaration de guerre
nous avons enquêté pour comprendre le
fonctionnement du racket sur les
chantiers de marseille
il s'agit en fait d'un système de
chantage à l'emploi
première étape les dégradations sur les
engins et les racketteurs montre aux
ouvriers que le chantier dangereux pour
eux comme ici sur un des tronçons de la
l2 le futur périphérique de marseille
nous découvrons une foreuse carbonisé la
veille
d'après le conducteur de travaux
l'agression n'a duré que quelques
secondes
[Musique]
les jeunes du quartier auraient lancé
des engins incendiaires sur cette
machine qui perce les tunnels de la l2
il s'agit de la plus grande force
d'europe
le coût de la tacc est exorbitant
les assaillants ont aussi brûlé deux
pelleteuses 600000 euros de préjudice
supplémentaire et plus d'un mois de
retard pour le chantier devant la
gravité de l'acte le conducteur de
travaux refuse de communiquer davantage
et nous demande de partir l'omerta est
totale le racket tout le monde le subit
mais personne n'en parle
pour terroriser les ouvriers les
agresseurs ne se contente pas des
dégradations
[Musique]
s'y ajoutent les intimidations physiques
le minimum syndical ce sont des menaces
de mort parfois cela va beaucoup plus
loin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi tous ces chantiers sont ils
attaquent et pourquoi les jeunes des
cités
cherche-t-il à terrifier les ouvriers
qui travaillent nous sommes allés
rencontrer ceux du quartier où la
foreuse a brûlé il refuse de parler de
racket pour eux il s'agirait d'un
problème d'emploi
[Musique]
madame nouveau le travail et ils sont
dans leur quartier le jeune ils ont bien
25 ans la plupart et ce même si vous
imaginez on vient travailler dans votre
quartier où vous avez pas travail
c'était travail des travaux excusez moi
que tout le monde peut faire c'est juste
des gens qui travaillent et donc ils
descendent
c'est vrai ils descendent ils disent
mais le chantier s'arrête parce qu'il
voulait travailler après pour nous ils
ont raison racket c'est un grand mot la
patate c'est juste des jeunes conduites
renvoyer ces jeunes nous livre la clé du
système l'embauchent
celui qui organise le racket envoie des
petites mains attaquer les chantiers
pour forcer les conducteurs de travaux à
employer des personnes de la cité en
retour les dégradations et les
agressions s'arrête des entrepreneurs
achètent ainsi leur tranquillité
[Musique]
il y a quelques années sur un chantier
marseillais
nous avions réussi à filmer ce moment où
tout se joue aujourd'hui le mode
opératoire est toujours le même le
racketteur est à chaque fois le
responsable d'une société de sécurité
locales ici on va répéter ce qu'on a dit
qu'il ne courait pas après avoir parlé
du chômage des jeunes du quartier
le discours se fait plus clair pour que
le chantier ne soit pas attaqué il faut
prendre leur entreprise de sécurité
on a envie de passer par une société de
gardiennage les gremlins ce sont les
jeunes de la cité voisine qui sont
envoyées pour dégrader les chantiers le
ton des racketteurs se durcit les
substituts les croix et en plus c'est le
jugement ils ont écrit ces mots
certains essayent de résister aux
pressions des racketteurs mais les
conséquences pour ceux qui ne payent pas
sont dramatiques
c'est la troisième étape les menaces
sont mises à exécution
mehdi on a fait l'amère expérience il a
presque 40 ans dont 15 passés à diriger
des chantiers dans les quartiers nord de
marseille
il y a quelques mois il a failli perdre
la vie gm de mes gars qui crie mon nom
mais tu me dis attention atteints sont
arrivés sont nombreux et je me retourne
et j'en vois je vois benga cagoulés avec
des couteaux y avait une espèce de veste
avec le s'était pas vous dire si c'était
un fusil à pompe
mais voilà c'était assez lâches comme ça
personnellement j'ai eu un clash
il durera moins de dix minutes arrivé
avec des cagoules et armés
c'est vraiment des gars a préparé un des
meurtres à des règlements de comptes ou
des trucs comme ça
seulement terrorisés mehdi s'enfuit et
se cache entre deux voitures attendant
que son supérieur viennent l'extraire en
urgence depuis l'incident mais dix vit
avec un contrat sur la tête
il a porté plainte pour menaces de mort
et agressions à main armée désormais le
chef de chantier est rentré dans le rang
sur ses nouveaux projets ils embauchent
des jeunes du trafic de drogue pour
acheter sa tranquillité
la méthode c'est de ses devoirs le bras
sport du proche du réseau et les tendres
avec lui directement
si j'ai négocié directement avec les
dealers mais tout ça j'ai plus de gens
de rentrer au port angie le voir mes
enfants
[Musique]
chaque année le racket à marseille coûte
plus de 50 millions d'euros au secteur
du btp
devant l'ampleur du phénomène un groupe
de trois magistrats et d'une dizaine de
policiers a été créé leur mission
démanteler les réseaux de racketteurs
marseillais leur premier fait d'armes à
l'arrestation il ya quelques semaines de
ceux qui ont attaqué la foreuse on
suspects interpellés pour extorsion de
fonds en bande organisée
ils risquent jusqu'à dix ans de prison
ferme
[Musique]
malgré les difficultés certains
chantiers honteux été menée à bien à
côté du vieux port derrière la mairie se
cache le vaisseau amiral du renouveau de
marseille qui fait la fierté de la
vinasse il y a dix ans cet imposant
bâtiment était encore un hôpital il
prend désormais soin des touristes les
plus fortunés c'est le premier hôtel
cinq étoiles de la ville
inauguré en avril 2013
après quatre ans de travaux et 100
millions d'euros investis
le palace de marseille propose près de
200 chambres ou suites et trois
restaurants
ce jour-là l'intercontinental accueille
en e2 marque dans cette berline noire
aux vitres fumées
l'artiste français vivant le plus coté
au monde
le sculpteur richard orleans qui il est
venu à marseille avec son fils pour
superviser l'installation de ses
sculptures dans les plus beaux endroits
de la ville 1
expliqué melzer continental marcel et à
12 secondes à main
ception les ravis de vous accueillir
dans notre hôtel est situé dans un
bâtiment du xviiie siècle
sinon à suivre monsieur très bien merci
alors vos impressions c'est vrai c'est
époustouflant soul arrivé comme ça c'est
un bâtiment immense
on dirait qu'il sort de l'histoire de
l'histoire
et puis avec toute cette variable se
trouve à cette rénovation résolument
ultra moderne
non c'est vrai c'est bluffant pour son
séjour marseillais
richard orleans qui a réservé l'une des
plus belle suite du palace bien merci
c'est sympa tout de suite à profitez
donc de cette ville centre at war
vraiment une vue imprenable et puis on
voit la bonne mère là on est vraiment on
est à marseille on peut pas se tromper
l'une des plus belles vues de marseille
qui ne s'apprécient pas que du balcon
premier vers votre salle de bain avec
cette très belle des noirs sur pied qui
nous permis y compris depuis de votre
main profitez de voir la bonne mère
depuis votre baignoire vous en coûtera
700 euros la nuit voilà messieurs
mais en ce jour parmi nous
le sculpteur et son fils habitué des
palaces internationaux sont conquis
j'adore le design
ouais c'est magique la terrasse à ces
super tendance quoi on pourrait se
croire à barcelone c'est marseille le
nouveau barcelone séduit par le luxe du
premier palace de marseille celui qui
expose dans les villes les plus branchés
de la planète a décidé d'y faire
installer l'une de ses oeuvres phares la
panthère rouge dont la cote dépasse les
cent mille euros
et voici donc votre sculpture fièrement
installé face à notre dame de la garde
le vieux pas richard line ce qui tient à
sortir ses oeuvres des musées
ça permet de faire valoir un de mes
concepts et savoir d aller vers le
d'aller vers le public et ça c'est pas
le public qui viennent au musée du coup
de manière c'est encore une notion de
partage et de gens se prennent en photo
qui fera donc ils sont désagréables
oui exactement by prennent des poses et
se mettre en dessous c'est assez drôle
d'ailleurs il joue avec chaque emblème
du renouveau de marseille a donc eu le
droit à sa sculpture de richard orleans
qui l'intercontinental bien sûr mais
également le toit des terrasses du port
inauguré en 2014 ce centre commercial
flambant neuf est aussi le haut lieu des
nuits marseillaise
ce soir des milliers de marseillais sont
réunis pour fêter l'installation d'une
des oeuvres majeures de richard le king
kong rouge dont le prix tutoie les
sommets du marché de l'art
en effet récemment s'est vendu aux
dangers à 700 millions berne à new york
que monaco saint tropez pour marion
l'une des gérantes du roof top marseille
entre enfin dans le cercle fermé des
villes mondiales les plus branchés
[Musique]
après cet événement endiablé leur est
désormais pour richard orleans ski de
regagner sa suite d'à côté la bonne mère
de squatter l'hôtel et avait l'espèce de
continuité et voilà et puis à ma
sculpture au milieu comme ça on
appartient
mais non c'est vraiment sympa un hôtel
cinq étoiles et à quelques centaines de
mètres le quartier le plus pauvre de
l'hexagone un paradoxe qui résume bien
la problématique marseillaise keny
arkana la star du rap marseillais en a
fait une chanson tout tourne en boucle
dans la ville marcelo dessine
rom est venue chambouler toute la
culture de la vie l'écart se creuse
autant la frac
de la rupture la capitale de la rupture
détient le record de france de
l'inégalité l'écart entre les plus
riches et les plus pauvres et de 1 à 7 à
l'échelle nationale à marseille
il est de 1 à 15